[Music]
oulaï thononais one man bet vasco
gomes iam from global cities at fort
saint-père security products anathos 1 to
3.6 at globo digital services leaders
generating canvas belong euros either
pimp read certain dates five
biljana to offer them income in ivry  yes
you understand in the number of a train that
spins an employee towards its 28 countries
in governance the former blue bulls al
hay river google aaron from artificial
intelligence machine learning houses
cloud and digital world place indies
initiative whi embed hour we fight
security product  solutions and security
platform for baptise la tuilerie to
secure 10 service is to customers with
opened sows and go there
paris london dallas in us way we welcome
customers just like hubert reeves
rivals google and yahoo engineers to
note also an engineer causes
concepts ranging from  15 to 69 years old louis
baillot innovation strategy 6 1 6 1
promised everyone itself where we will rock
you are in a crisis of a
multiple applications using digital
transformation 'business unit' of the two
weekly dates of also and nabeul sap in
cloud for clunkers wi-drive maureille
stronger tool than stoner in terms
of cloud connecting offer in haiti world tower
wild hunt prem service precisely digital
see  pelé 6 2 phonetag auto
collaborative oriental collaboration in
office story five jesuit over grand
service à z
artificial intelligence invest
strongly customers 9 rue jean google
technology a finger of one pointois
will la focus to day in hybrid cloud for
our customers in à prime en  premium a
public to the environment a
bearish opinion kelly focus home security and
start am old concept drive lives
should be a tube i basic and savior
of standing between while stood
at north sails and clean service
providers
it is at the 600m  Darne of summer the
coming back from de public cloud while in
top shape partisan service is
because he 1-2 all their debts or
that tab  10-10 concept of chair of
responsibility
which is now it's getting to speak
before attacking reading customer titles
when we move out of service any
infrastructure as a service provider we
still responsible for the way we
configure or virtual network
or filing workloads  of platforms
of applications affected by an accident
snow but an ultimate and livni nasa this
mode we are still responsible for data
and of gartner predicts date or three
titles in title i death of a type nine
persons of the security feel better this
despicable tab  access control of an
investigation
or under machines at the web
application firewall where it is
important to focus then security
technologies as well as its services
co-wrote one we move to cloud and
where we are it is clear that we pass  ya spa
cnsas service is and making sure that we
know where is most thus type data and
where it's been moved to win it right
and start
it takes another identity editor of 8
yet to know where is  from moos and steve
from ohio state
even les fruits dongo toi crowd data
classification model at least identify
two words site yves datas in order to
apply watabe leaviss from body domain
security request for support to protect from
tabriz managing identity and access  and
offer who paulin object darracq these
signals data we try objects kz1 speak
about you tube explained either your any
kind of machine is only nine servers
applied chanel pillay noted access in
your data we resort time signature
india ap registrations  both words
it's city data domino points to will
show it later with no points that
don't apply strong crippen tour place
date to so you should aurélie focus in a
word it's evans control want you used
as you sony d'also  to control your eyes
open network and you be more and more
difficult à souissi date de ben jerry's
art expanding en date
when we speak and we think about the
fact that we or en pib then business in
his views not only your ya  ssa v6 from
dassault sas 5.6 like it's the effort
be beautiful jesuit dropbox from india from new
perimeter business offers it driven
by from date to date is moving sweet the
epic any more about bas explains maurel
dead to beat  of data perimeter where
data moving remained in date big
challenge winston india or in surf
therapy as well as controls from
nevers to sion beaten to roland ries
passerby secure nothing
worth trying still have to really focus we
have no detect india  and our
minor friend a senior pri was
all evans always who has a destiny of also
or
configuration may have liste or may have
ever seen and then in order to make sure
that you know we were here is not a
moving focus on controlling the  use of
sas a v6 mass invest
lessors like elsewhere in the country bays or
by business in it on a 10 mousli she
crowds in dubai solutions it like it be
cloud accessible in fifteen years from
gartner lease practice
twenty twenty two sixties pers  on of life
will use akasbi white ou des ja finchem
proximity liters tool person to which
understanding the use of shadow haiti en
saas best employees will also have
no you to b their target i was circulating
insecurity bernes india identified or
new services are being adopt lease  to
employees a whole and in the service sector
or offers to you please secure
alternative so what would say that we
mousli forgotten is that securities not
only azannaï from here stadia Zionist
as leader number one concerns way for
a clown or public the  germany rich
program it's also paradoxical and of
number three driver fort moufte le cloud
which isync cloud technology for me ah
si damazin opportunity to do security
bearer we need to shift the host of our
27-28 adopt 19 is that ten new
technology  to be able to and that the
are aware without obstacle of the
troubles not even to take two with the added
bonus of a challenge that has public cloud mode the
young girl camille abbott verte  a
machine that with up we swim here worse
environmental soa boot of
possibility to automated lyon fra
structure asa strong code
automatic deployment ali to have workflow too much
it is what hovers or imitable
infrastructure and disease way for us to
deliver automatons of security
setting security  agency embedding then
security agency thing in two of template
hope for haiti where 1 of the degrees our
machines in the way to make
sure okay control by deploying consists
a clip it also helps in terms of
security said
they cause if you are show your  this
temple is to be reconfigured you know how
you production is right one that once
yes yes yes yes yousif strategies saint
louis we move to a more at all
she is beautiful infrastructure a
horizontal scalability were we ask
to grant that the load of  customers yes
provisions new machine ce we will moufte
way we were to world where 2 traditional
legacy static firewalls split ignore
a sentence let's be a two  three year for
things will not be enough any more c'est
au control in it still here we still be
critical important control what we
call from north south communication
internet forums to you to your surroundings
from your own all take there will be to
close  the environment it is offered to the
dead secure jones versus intranet but
you will have done to ensure al sawda
thiou monitor what is happening between
you mind your world which can be virtual
machine out of container to follow micro
segmentation so in france in security
controls filing  intrusion prevention his
packet inspection
a twin goering evry machine
eastleigh bridging lease the tag label
onions machine star
san finna timing would have said adopt
devoxx bail
worried is too much like your
clothes newell's old boys are doing so
said anyone  fore
professional insecurity dual soyuz date in
order to automata value of falling
skies wii one thing that are we do is
peachy to theirs prop  res left at
dawn security vendor to make sure
air date and adopts unified security
posture of april explains the author which
is one five roles console all orchestrated
yesterday solution to butt takes the
form and public life forms and we've 10
plate 10.5 role console in 2 of security
wenders bing openskies meaning 17 10
epic win it be security king
malfunction we will be better to make
10 holy solution oldies benders working
together a blink at 9.2 but a
security yeah but there  did you have in
situ the holders they use of
speed of closing of north one attack at the
heart of spirit is security event of
coming from blog gold a myth
configuration of the tumors detected
sovo nomine date a forcing date wii
ware and bull tout prix au volume  is an
orchestra is safe
they are finished 2010 that fervor gesture g
slate ep121 skip stew estiot
application saw your application
security and sting tools to help you drop
a destiny douich venables it is  davinder
code rate of business code of business
applications dader developing and open
source libraries moreover using
application security testing whether
they are adopting
gods and thank god has it
editors and for most critical the night
is krayt ticket you want
to fix yourself ticketing managed at soyaux development
aids you as they knew bug fix for them
1-2 want sweden we have all date de next
up into you make your  production finally
when you have fun party solution or a
piece of code stirs up young Arabs at
night very small
you need to pacini death of production
what you need to do is up des templates
d'accord mansion 2 linking dakar
templates un test name and then you
production the environment to be renault
told him simple is subjected to a
hot at you kill you kill your
existing workloads ina
structure unduly s  tarting with the new
template this we don't have to negotiate
any more with what was one of de penfoul
parts negotiating maintenance windows
wild 2 yes the business which he always
said
in the time to know there is no more
downtime or widi strategy y ait un
flight you kill de machines en start
your hands and when you have done that
you can't touch de logic forbach dancing
date you you don't need your machine
your  clothes as arts multiple
horizontal lines i to be up
one single whine up for ever you can 7
seven tweets does not expire elections times and
towers
is to be at lion workloads or
the explorer and have a humor auto
scalability engine win  win monitor finally
a jeep it manager a group stand will
monitor de workload if 10th workload was
necessary and chris pine ap new one
starting fario templates so you know
that your environment twinbee re nude
after hours complete environment  ment
publishes roniu of after hours three races
10 applicable only to application the
part compatible datar claude native
application compatible widi the approach
that we move forward the moving from
monolithic applications all say
claude native applications so when you
date drunk move of persistence in fuel
environment  a make it harder ford
attackers to discover your
environments and will have to wall
hover day one day start plugin a
bullfighting assistant to troyan our
environments it will be removed after
hours of course
10en the valid ones if you make sure of atur
des cases note des  keynotes temper wilbur
templates a hard templates because you
most valuable this going goodyear data
saw one thousand on these dates 10
introduction oise ritoo focus family in
gold we don't protect in data in nude
code attacks on the template a from
date to date a drive in  business and our
application
wen that's a battle it's me who
goes door to door for a data
security force s  aintrick futur à will focus on
tout futur data winehouse identity and
access management and inscriptions so
forth very quickly as you leave
distinguish finatis pretty client for ever
will which is how dirty providers lippi
working with samuel one customer ou à
newser dude sarko is where all the
environment chlorine all google closer to j
sequel of the game leaning so jesuit
he introduces himself luigi sequel
login page login movie enter the log in
vasco dot gomes haste
atos to be 1.10 rudy rayton read again
act of two days and  provider configure
de fordo another name in which is f
form party provider ou r who we have
federated jewish identity
so what's this past and provider oui
mais que sarko est tout de tout de users
and then you pay to use or use of
hunters à sword of  enemy hunters over
authentic and that method to be strong
any factor or applications in less
than ten seconds from the dati provider
validate dryden city of the user 1.10
context access this context a  delivers to
token gobball to use a secret
both of clubs service provider of you
there isn't it up to present 10 token
that the locle to the service provider which
can then halloween access all
environments
the ones who else this date a
fog  atos has household globules
security services company delivering
service is to offer de cloud while
raiding
that it was dead suddenly a
strong group mres difficulty which is all
women and all his complicates cities of
every customer in venice on a notre lit
provider a accessit one multiple this
offer koubbi solution to the service now
software as a service on the service chains
now tiko office story five is not
worse gateway the capital so desists
complexity complexity any household
conflict if all adopt you have to its
followers  environments everywhere one
of also walked in
another multiple
mon compatible there that tibco spotfire jump 10
what we've done is transforms soluti  ons
to be to work azan adipi router hadopi
provider hooters swiss steel que de
christophe cann style oral agonist adam
type riders moreover the author
of the marquette mines to a we don't touch
and sing and is just go forward of a
corner is dj school of two functions
of futuris that the where are you from
featuring a week so we do when the
office governed suite provide the squid of
huy authentication finally yes it's
top
owen wright also via web access manager
has heidi fort  service provider one of
you one or one of the customer
environmental
yes it boosts atos and biden wamaza nabi
azad claude service provider saves
a certain self into the chain and we ll
never made to be simplify internal management
monitoring and so for this is only one
eye deep in which is our lady peace and
then that we can plug hour identity
governance and administration solution
suite
workflow management would certification
solution which will be which will ces
amphora  s de customer information
security officer tim ash single location
where to define holder profile software
bringing profile crowds profile
indicated mme fans for every
profane role or from their team art a
short stop at the bistro falcou bee linux
administrator and seppi and
seppi administrator koubbi folder  organizer
finally an executive
assistant assistant a collaborative form
services 10 is defined in control
location and we are we are adapting for
profile templates d'oublie multi cloud
multi cloud had label so what and
customer wants to move workload from one
club ohada hanover or move d  a
migration from a competitor all I
said yes and 2 in china joe hill 2 and
change templay this idiocy our
solutions
we just automatically provision ali of
the accessory and this in two groups those
users from previews environment
hearing provision  woods and people to
google cloud identity métis 2nd model
offer google all provision from us
all of us link provision of
group users access rights in google in the
bissau and annabelle cities of migration
and from a closed service provider everything
i have 6 pi either disease we work will be
single we provide single point of
administration
aso fort precisely on 2  6 to 10
provides a au single loca chinoise and
thus every other props
will come back on every other au père
claude service providers when you do an
audit you don't have listen to go to
every afur claude service providers
layer high speed gysi  fidji following their
salesforce box google you think rigautou
de evidian à tous et viviane interfaith
un youyou ci ou intel titled to which
roll over all your clothes off from
there you have traceability over
activities which also give you a single
button in ningbo town where you  can have
or an employee leave the company you just
got consoles you delete your move is
it was said to be or it was invented
great and you ready has two objectives  s
yes detects wii see drivers of
users 10 to pitre from your yoro
directory and we automatic is free
finally heidi pipart tough to the solution
to communicate and yes two identical
governance administration all a
provision of custom hours except
children
j 6 pi wagne orange  y follows a group
provisions anna when angie following
authentic user is hoisted
active shirt or two weeks melee folk so when
you there is hmoud
or is
ghosn facelift of a type of company
even if you move it from your directory
of claude zidi customs session  in any
case as far cry for teen daze so if
them
when your home movies at when they
exchange if i had operation from is
is owned and managing vice horizon
laptop in drome 10 session can be still
open ardor if they  validate for some days
and illfurth in the one way of one way of
a forcing in rom or venice and its
chances bouby to go to from jpy console
is oval access to egypt console
jesuit console hindu
d'o  ù a password reset weekend of this
as you have to do is 10/10/10 ou alward
meanings Zionist automatic wind
is automatic and the s2 despite the
texts at 12:30 p.m.
solution a painful and boozy louis
right away any
password reset eynden kg hl de cession de
possibility that he used guys are and
less with you say date le strain
web site qu'apple web access management alibi
inde identity governance a very dear friend
we provide single point of admitted very
young wipro hui to void one to user
customer
spencer a new world service provider i
don't have to re confusion au lisa deep
is we just do it from de m clan
solution india yes by doing that we  have
had assaults of complexity in à claude
migration of adapting to the lion access either
arthur's first fan club over its
very identity and access management model
of this hippies very different from his
co  mpetitors this roic rugby which blocked
form moving from strong moving from a
competitor to your clothes from
competitors all j 6 pi because you
have to not only noon the game complexity
in full move in your clothes mellal
saves from complicity we adapt lignon to m
when luigi  strategy ue has reconquered
delicacies form 10 110 is your own a
sedative to yann sommer the urban managing
will there be a size access to
you what is in some guys who you can also
for you must see type data or a  twin
crypte des indes in the city by default
all your data zareen crypton sow j lipid
2d folk inscriptions tell me footings cription
and lucienne left of de
of the picture is is done weave de faire
default key management server where you
have no control new access  you cannot
revoke registration that they you cannot
this pin up different registrations that
they provide an environment a
back for that google has a cool service
customer management crippen that they get
involved w  erritty basic there are 200
services on sap ja which
management server francs google puts ten
timing wav an inovaccess interface all
the google which puts which management server
and you can affects 10 frenchies to
different
business unit sodifrance business
applications revolt is you can'  t take
is so when you have cycle 8i dobbs in order
to bring the pledges of talika chick 'n
go to 2 which management server then
evokes two that they taulhac dead against
old style foursomes customers and don't
want to put all day all  days in the same
basket made of being at the peak or of effort
asked of moussa sy type data and where far
from you come to check in as soon as they
mourn kees aarts general ted creator
of wez de ski are store of soho fort
of adoption in google wekiss could do we
offer to try to which could google
custom overtime line crippen that they
invite nepean in front of offers
google communicating leave your key
management server data and cost on loan
dead in after-v  ente cloud and which
enables you to use your own solutions to
generate from fayoum which management server
to generate that they establish name and
when to google cloud services need which
must all provided troussi as
is this weekend and crypt of duty
claude computer  sous disease and spoke
about about the need to classified tour
des stands bio data you could not use
only solutions from date google
a guide to you
registration that instead of the dates in
kozmino of more you go to 2 to of
control of dead against instead of van
nho that they of the ess compatibility web
google jcp services of description of
course
is this compatible with all and jc then
project  from customer manager encrypts a
crisis on word black version you have
access to from guy management server or
google it is compatible wifi g 6 pi
applications de lier registrations in jpy
products google cloud s  beckett torage
google computer and virtual machine big
willie data proc hain to swiss pic google
is nothing of incompatibility batistyl
not all the products and when you go to
bring your own which strategy if so
what is like only complain
shiite issue in him  compatible weave
google cloud storage and google
captain john smit you you it's in the
balance issa bargain showcase of trust 1
jilliti of more you go to of
death control received before control of your
data encryption that they of the ess
google web compatibility  knew if this
jersey moss so type data for the
most critical data you might not need to
have to do to you all of google
invests in book was specifically
so that's one line dance all we alpes
you to do is to make sure that  you can't
you can get up from best approach between
10 industrial string ovens into you
sensitivity three beyond these dates
so i want my knees registration tools
used in disguise
on a spock  outskirts of defects
registrations
a 2 2 who is dying on the spot of a crime that
they see yuzuki management server
and new hope you lice on october 3 at ty
ar blackened quest for the module called hope
you know it's you can fort greeter trust fr
de  greeters entropy twitter
randomization of the keys general of the
elbow generate malware wanyou generated
tekki software use of random works
of except of the parking system which is
will leave the ja bell in the fire for
balances which of a hardware rebels
says optional or all that  is always
using cloud provider incriptions tools
so in dekese where you bring your own
who uses christopher flexible and crimson
who solves france google which is
still solutions on styles need you
to bring your who at any time top
2 crips your data sauvaud and don  't
have access to all you written pink is all
time this moment of user entitled users
to 3.2 off need to access data from
keynes all progress from both
clubs provider be it  decrypt data
improbable both a crypt clear to
2 to the user on the first name is how
can we build have more control en de
krypton and he is born and cription to lead
safe and reply to use
sié sic and former mickey when you
register  in google not use your own
who management server india a fan of the
rhône incriptions solution to our
couple problem of who all and all
all these sites and soan solution which is
called atos data protect atos trustway
natta protect in the cloud bull who
management server mba  given a hardware
security module datsyuk and our stands
prem or in warned claude what you in
atos weekend delivery you have a service
the jump or r2 which engineering ted here
and manage distort a 10th is it
an oversight provide connectors a summer  rich
in living water or a crystal systems in
linux windows intel widi the
bitumen rules registration table sql
virtual machine registrations application
registrations and organizations use
e  n reading and pressing web data in tokyo a
little ping at the index in distortion can we
also have connector for mongodb hadoop
and multiple currencies over service is
so schedules
for more than one service ing cipi and
using 10 service this weekend in  strong
provide the keys to you prove
relays that discipline and google india
at 20 singles pineau ice cream has single
control single console all control
instead cription between my we do not provide
this service is in saas services
andrew cosby show integrated everything is
connected to  banks of the same 15 bis
providers net cut
mcafee nvision Or six sky blue coat date
is now by symantec a louis yves direct
line creeping data in office rhys ifans
s on foot salesforce
jce 8 and 7 June wil wheaton so it
esitmant specific to give a then
warned of what is in the right is off
private cloud digital private cloud
which we deliver everything breeders able to
say to customers yes I am your
disciple so what does dallas where it strong
large companies and  to
deploy registration solution a crypt a
strategy strong turmoil aroused data
on database in virtual machine zone file
system which will bring the single
single console console where you are
full visibility in two registrations
police officers that have been there so you
don't have  discrete penalty discrepancy
over two registration algorithms
registration required of a compost use in
oracle database orignal linux file
system one single console you can see at
the most physical when you want to know
when a tripple example of assize
consider of a secure you can  move it
from all you solutions from one single
annual location valls to traceability
everytime any one has ascad and got it
and access to and crips yankees
toad is enabled bring their control
but the conference is your audit console
one thing that has always better world
is  that when you security control of a
soccer fade in order to wei trouillot
firewall rules have used and zero day and
night by yo  ur eyes piece the intruder
private channel youth sensor signature gold web
application firewall signature of when
you have been in one design banbridge of
finale of finale protection is have you
be a view a crypt hard data in othe
jump ringtones say betrayed focus
drive  encryption because before any
focus to date said strategy of having
a unified a troll console to manage
your security daughter security features and
that which solves over take a
public cloud or go to solutions
or at 9:02 a.m. from target should be applied and
even soon  view to all to all city
domains like for example davies one of
the biggest partners security partners
google offer we use palo alto palo
alto networks traditional forts
exane firewalls des f10 panorama console
dati a single single consoles these
console trolls and want to control everything r
between m  2 prime times on physical
palo alto firewalls india de highway l'az
de palo alto vm series huchard de
virtual applia  nce datsyuk by deploying
jessy pi a riff 10 cents role to nora my
console visibility at the heavy network
network for all roads wever
of week virtual network is he remembered
tangi cipi off isem net there will be
a bonus a strong at the security domains we
are pushing partners 22-22 carved
wenders to go to second strategy
whatever it the players on data loss
prevention and filed tijd wrote psion
a real security domain so swing swing
silver important titles vizix a troll
visibility fire control is that five
roles visibility  and strong where your data
is moving to deploy meadows in bubbles
control consists of cry have a right
and monitoring and control monitoring in
were offer to future event from à
sainte-rose location 10 andy wahloo air
billing and pop of james iam encryption
is for  delivering hall security service
public cloud environment use pop
art of two years from slide hand to
butt take all that even think he in
liberia security  regional orchestra
automation engine police officers n'djeng
security operations center and bolt or
orchestra is an automaton
of security solutions public arts wise solution
lord
or m all his rights
we need to eye focus on the data having
it focus on two days a  weekend bédard
use and access management cription to
protect data and everything as he was
focus in public during six holes strong
between m
one we should not forget is dates of the
three neighbors sowa of halloween the
first side is we have also to protect
grant  a model tower it takes
arenaria
a sentence a service delivery mode we
have to protect our application
contenders vm to practitioners of virtual
network those of what we do by this is
seniors bling gold precisely receive
beautiful hours at bellity to control data
by completely drunk and collins  it's one
way of it is one thing to have
deploy control outside our processes al haouz
youtube and compliance with regulation it
is another thing to b  e able to
demonstrative a fortnight security
breach happens if you will have to
democratic
so if i vtec mc2 example of things
cription a if you have your would have
that administered torso
nataf give body and khider jobs of avs
a crypt of words these sites  yves datas
a database crypt or from tempel
stordiau me it's the one yves datas
matthews there would only be all of them you
have the sing sing for you linux
administrators step gives 10 strong
dervite to dorff assystem du drill
seppi or to come
so  i was all 10-10 team's taf gives der
jobs that we write in indulgent silo
with a troll visibility in which will
fall in which inscriptions algorithms
which is linked that they d are using so
you will have long dress time to go to
every  to the victims
ascq des mre porte local de
configuration all monsters and or
their bubble and gold gold everything is said in titi
n'attise casting how to prove date
nature you are complete and hate you
have famous disc would have claiming
disabled two inscriptions
tatar algorithms of arnaud moore considers of secure
for example jump 10 cents role a
marketing indicates blocks review this goal
10 it is a troll console if copenhagen
place for all sure security future is
and what is far from file data here
developing is for ya what
needs egg focusing we will do on this
service he of cloud security posture
management solutions lie credoc
daunizeau obvious tailheuret of the
cabin what she is talking about back pain
threatens binczak tip bic the artist
presents  divx presented yesterday in brixton in
google next 6 p.m. boots an overband
claude passage 10 claude service
providers indices claude security
posture management art delivering format
single console hole and pierrick holtz
always environment in sanaa and a
young ben omar and pia zar agentless in
work eyes a mourning  before and lives in
this darkness against city policies of
colitis and their controller policies that
it rules a best practices of habi  tants
of the tests and environments all
checks that were completed in addition
blatt
the mosquito bio example art is do you
have to a bug is open a stiffness and
in read write the world of to come
all the machine
ivan ferroul halloween all access 0 2 0
2 0
la géraud and ni access are due to view
10.1 goodies and foot that they
hang on the lions and fiore multi
claude olio claude environment one of the
view guides allaerts strong finally from
saturday 10 all for centers tell me
claude petit posture management
solutions it will also open to claude
all kinds party and will be able to
work as a troll console we
control all all your lover security
control
[Music]